America's most iconic toy store chain
full of everything from bikes to trains
to video games plans to start closing
all of its Us stores you're gonna be
singing that all day long
Toys R Us announced plans to liquidate
overnight over 70 years in business it
will close or sell at 735 US locations
including its Babies R Us stores the
move means around 30,000 employees will
lose their jobs CBS News business
analyst Jill Schlesinger is here to look
at the ripple effect this will create
Jill good morning this one I think
really hurts because it was so fun as a
kid to walk through Toys R Us stores
looking at the aisles of stuff that you
can't get but then you would want to
dream about and everybody wanted to be
at Toys R Us kids yeah so they filed for
bankruptcy in September take us through
the timeline
what happened that it didn't work out
well they were really hoping for a very
strong holiday season and the holiday
season was quite disappointing now
remember the whole reason they went into
bankruptcy was sort of a convergence of
bad timing and bad decisions they did a
deal in 2005 with a private equity firm
it saddled the company with five billion
dollars worth of debt at the same time
online sales growing and becoming a huge
player in the toy market and also we
should note that the actual tastes of
kids started to shift away from physical
toys to technology on their phones and
you put it all together and it was a
rough go and as you said about 33,000
employees looking at losing their jobs
this is all happening literally as we
speak they will begin the process those
folks will get paid for 60 days we
should also note if you ou have a Toys R
Us gift card try to use it online we
just went on the website it's there but
it's going to become worthless if you
don't use it quickly what are the impact
do you think this is gonna have on the
entire toy industry well I think the
larger makers so you look at sort of a
Mattel has ro they're gonna be hurt for
a while because this was a big outlet
for them but they also have a unique
opportunity because they may go out and
start gobbling up smaller toy makers and
beefing up their
businesses that may be a really good
growth opportunity because smaller
retailers are going to have a harder
time placing their products this is I
know a very sad time for a lot of people
Gail's nostalgic the CEO is nostalgic I
get that you know Jeffrey the giraffe
gone from the endangered to the extinct
list now but I really want to point out
this was a lot about management a lot of
bad decisions and again that debt
crippled them and we should know they've
been iconic American brands that have
gone into bankruptcy and re-emerged
later on absolutely yeah Jill
Schlesinger thank you so much